foreign
yo yo
we're here
oh
one sec
foreign
um
we're live we're live now Yoshi we're
live now did you know that I do know
that yes uh just for us the background
so you switch it so we can see the other
people because we can just see your face
oh is that what you want to see how
about that yeah there it is oh
how exciting so welcome back to hot
breath everyone the show where you learn
comedy from the pros this is our weekly
live stream we do every Tuesday on our
YouTube channel
so please join our email list so you can
get updated on when we're going live and
all the other fun goodies we have for
all the subscribers over there and we
got a goodie today Yoshi goody goody
goody
you and I we're not only you know
working comedians in the stand-up world
but we also like to do work in the
corporate world and our guest today he's
someone we've talked about for a while
he's someone we've taken inspiration
from and uh we can check out his work on
LinkedIn a lot and we're excited to have
him on the show man this is gonna be a
good one especially when we get into
that corporate goodies that our wife
enjoys
um you know our wives enjoy when our
comedy gets paid uh more in one day than
you may make it a weekend at a comedy
club so
yeah when it comes back in more than
tater tots she's like oh wow look at you
look at you
don't cry so let's get to it man without
further Ado hot breadthiverse welcome to
the show The One and Only Mr Dave
schwenson everyone
Dave happy Tuesday
I just want to say you guys are talking
about all excited about today's show and
I just roll around here your standards
are pretty low no
[Laughter]
so you're talking about your wife I walk
in here too and I got no respect here
either so
it's good to be here thank you for
asking me guys thank you absolutely
we're excited to have you man uh you
know uh as Joel mentioned we've been on
this like corporate uh comedy grind of
like how do we break in how do we get in
how do we get more corporate stuff and I
think we've all been we all have gotten
just like a little taste of corporate
and we've done a couple of gigs and
we're like all right how do we do a lot
of those gigs so where I don't have to
do the gig where I'm getting paid in a
beer ticket and here's a drink ticket
all right
you know I always tell people when they
uh you know I've been doing comedy
workshops for way too many years and you
know business workshops and things with
Comedians and when I talk about the
corporate Market you know a lot of
comics don't understand the different
markets they think it's just comedy
clubs that you get on television then
you get a sitcom you're famous and
that's it but you know there's I always
say the comedy clubs are almost like the
low rung on the ladder because you know
I mean you got cruise ships colleges and
corporate shows to make some real money
and uh as an example I tell them uh when
they come in they say you know I say
sometimes you'll notice the headliner
like you're expecting oh wow somebody
somebody's coming in I've been knowing
about this for months I can't wait to
see them and then like you know a week
or two before they're headlining a
comedy club somewhere you know they've
been
not you know canceled or delayed you
know okay the show's been canceled we're
going to reschedule and that person will
be back and they're all thinking God I
hope they're okay I hope they're not
sick I hope nothing bad happened no they
probably got a corporate gig that will
pay them for one hour what they're gonna
make in the entire weekend I mean that's
what it is hey man I got a corporate gig
so let's put this back a month or two
whatever you have an opening
so uh that's a great example of how it
works
that's awesome so how how would you say
you got started I guess
give us a little history of your path
your comedy path from the beginning
because a lot of our audience may not
know who you are we've researched you we
know who you are we've seen we've seen
the books we've seen the LinkedIn we're
both I think both of us kind of stalk
you on LinkedIn just yeah
we're just like how's he doing it
it's all about networking guys you know
when we talk about the business this
stuff it is all the days of just showing
up and being funny somewhere I mean you
can do it if the right place the right
time of course but it's it's all
marketing and it's it's getting yourself
out there because the competition is so
tough you got to be able to stand out
from the competition my story is very
long so I'll just uh briefly highlight
it I started back uh uh New York City
give us the five or five minute version
of it yeah
like I did I mean when I first went to
New York City I
you know I graduated with a degree of
business from a college in Ohio
University and I want to be in Show
Business and there was no show business
out here so uh I went to New York City
and I got involved and I started doing a
lot of things I mean I used to perform
music down to the clubs in the village
for years all the Kenny's Castaways and
The Back Fence all those places uh I
used to add jokes in between the songs
too
um didn't mean I could sing any better
but it just uh maybe I'd entertain them
more uh I learned about the comedy
Business from The acting World actually
are the the entertainment business I
used to do soap operas believe it or not
and uh some commercials films things
like that nothing to quit my day job to
support myself with but I did a lot of
stuff and uh good friend of mine I'll
mention his name Chris Murphy it's a
comedy coach in New York City guys are
walking Encyclopedia of Comedy when
people are going to New York I always
recommend check him out uh he was a
stand-up comedian and I'm like you know
he got me interested in doing it so I
said so I took a workshop in New York
City to do three minutes stand up comedy
and I'll tell you right now it's not
anywhere near as good as my workshop
I still say the guy still say the guy
never even knew our names three minutes
of Comedy it was just it was kind of a
ridiculous kind of thing years and years
later when I was a talent coordinator
this guy used to come into the club I
was booking shows for they would stand
there and look at me like how do I know
this guy how do I know this guy and I'm
thinking you never even knew me when I
was in your Workshop okay anyway that's
my you're not bitter but you're not
bitter I mean he's still not doing it
I'm not bitter I think it's funny as
hell
[Laughter]
he's probably still wanting how do I
know this
um but that's part of networking you
know you never know who's gonna be who
in this game that's why you got to be
nice to everyone it is I make a point of
that you know don't don't burn any
bridges yeah you know don't I've heard
that too many stories horror stories
these Comics that uh again they burn
some bridges they're jerks they go out
somewhere and they're not invited back
and they don't understand why well
figure it out you know um if it's too
comics and kind of equally funny you
don't know which one to pick you're
gonna pick the one that's easiest to
work with bottom line
um I learned that real quick
um anyway I got interested in comedy I
started my own comedy club with my
friend Chris in New York City down at
20th Street and Third Avenue Gramercy
Park area there was a bar there at the
time that's not there anymore uh we
started doing comedy shows on Friday
Saturday nights and I got to be the MC
which means you know I was always on
stay I get my stage time the most
important thing is stage time one reason
we did it because we couldn't get on
stage with the open mics because we'd
walk in it was all kind of clicky still
clicky these things yeah so what we did
was we started a better Club than
everybody else had
honestly I'm not bragging when I say
this we did a Friday Saturday night most
open mics are Sunday Monday Tuesday and
they're hunting for an audience we would
pack this place and everybody wanted to
get on stage and it was like cool I'll
put you up on five minutes and then when
I show up at your Club you're gonna put
me up
that's why I start yeah that's where I
started meeting some of the comics I
worked with later I mean I'll drop their
names at that we call it the bar was
called the Honey Tree and we renamed it
the funny tree just for the weekend
shows and um
oh my gosh I mean that's where I met
David tell the first time and uh Mark
Maron uh Brett Butler the Wayans
brothers Sean and Marlon would come in
uh you know a lot of that
group I just started to meet that group
we did that for about six months and
I'll say it was pretty successful and I
but I wanted to get into the best clubs
and really the only one I thought of was
The Improv the New York improv that's
one I'd heard of my entire life you know
the New York improv so I went up to get
my foot in the door just to get a job
like a lot of people do you know a
doorman bartender whatever let you know
let the owner who was silver Saunders at
the time let her get to know that I can
do this so uh I went up and introduced
my actually Chris Murphy introduced me
to her he was working the coat room at
the time
could do anything to get in and uh she
said I said I was looking to to get a
job and she says can you bartend I'm
like sure
you know I could open a can of beer
so she made me the Sunday night
bartender okay that's great I'm in and
then uh I learned that my first Sunday
networking that's when I learned how
cheap comedians are because they were
the only ones hanging around the bar the
convicts way to go on
you know they get a free drink and then
they're drinking club soda the rest of
the night and I get stiffed I'm like
okay this is not a good business
opportunity anyway I was counting I was
counting out the money at the end of the
night and it's the only time in my whole
life I said my business degree came in
handy because I was right on the mark
right on the penny count it right down
perfect and Silver's standing there like
I think she was amazed because I think
the earlier bartenders couldn't do that
through a lot of mistakes and she said
would you like to be the assistant
manager I said sure
so I came back the next night Monday and
I was the assistant manager and they she
trained me Monday and Tuesday I would be
the assistant manager and then this only
lasted for about two weeks and there she
had a manager I won't mention his name
but I really loved this guy he was a
good guy helped me out a lot he'd been
there for a while and the two of them
had this banter going on these arguings
they would do anyway they got in some
fight so she fired him turned around to
me and said you're the manager
okay
yeah so the first thing I did was pass
myself as a comedian
[Music]
[Laughter]
doing the shows I mean I had to learn
the comics she taught me so much silver
I owe her so much she just passed away
not too long ago but you know how to
book shows how to so how was the talent
Booker for the club it was also the
manager of the club you know I mean you
know seeding the customers in the
kitchen and the servers overlooking
everything but also booking the shows
and uh I remember I would give myself
like a five minute set
I stopped doing that
well number one I didn't want to take
time away from the real Comedians and I
was getting more behind the scenes but
also I went up and really struggled to
do a five six minute set I was having a
hard time then after me Rodney
Dangerfield went on
wow I was like oh come on this is not
good so uh but I really got into the
behind the scenes stuff so I would get
calls from you know Late Night with
David Letterman Comedy Central HBO The
Tonight Show MTV and they would be
looking for comedians to put on they
want to showcases they were asking me
who are The Comedians they should see
you know types you know political Comics
family Comics whatever it might be so I
was putting together these showcases and
they would come in and pick what Comics
they wanted to put on the TV show I
really like that and um I did that for a
while and then I got tired of being cold
quite honestly and uh so I moved to
Hollywood
and I hooked up there with Bud Friedman
and you all know who Bud Friedman is
if you have anyone watching this if you
think you're in the comedy industry you
don't know who Bud Friedman is you're
not in the comedy industry
he just passed away not too long ago
also and I learned so much I was Bud's
assistant
and then I became Talent coordinator for
the Hollywood Improv
and then also the television show a e is
an evening at The Improv
so I really I talk about experience you
know and again I was Consulting at that
time too because all the TV networks and
film studios were all out there so you
know I get calls from Disney and
Paramount and all the networks and I can
set up showcases for them and um all the
big agencies and everything and then
after a while I came back I grew up in
the midwest outside of Cleveland
and I came back here and started my own
business
um booking shows and I still stuck with
the Improv because there was an improv
in Cleveland there still is I managed
that for a while too I'm the only matter
of fact here's here's something for you
here's something for you I'm the I'm the
only person ever
in the history of the Improv to manage
to be the talent Booker from coast to
coast to coast New York City Los Angeles
and Cleveland which is on the North
Coast Lake Erie
so there you go nice and and since the
new since the New York City Club is no
more nobody else could ever say that but
me
uh but when I came out here uh
working in New York and Hollywood the
main focus was you know the comedy clubs
and getting on television getting a
sitcom you know all the comics were
doing it at that time you know I mean
There Was You Know Jerry Seinfeld and
Drew Carey and Ray Romano and Brett
Butler and uh they were all you know Tim
Allen
um so that was like the main focus it
and when I was in those cities I'd never
thought at all about corporate gigs
colleges
uh cruise ships it never crossed my mind
and I I don't we were focused on
television films and you know the Improv
the clubs
and um when I came out in the midwest
that's where I got my experience in
those markets
so again when I talk about doing my
comedy workshops and yeah I am a comedy
coach and I I do encourage you know help
writing original comedy sets performing
everything I mean I get people on stage
but my What Separates Me from everyone
else doing this is my background in the
business behind the scenes
you know I mean Comics can say they did
The Tonight Show Comics could say they
auditioned for The Tonight Show but they
weren't hanging around with the guys
deciding who was going to be on The
Tonight Show because they were looking
at 10 other people
so I was fortunate to do that through
bud bud Friedman and um but when I came
out here yeah it was a whole different
thing all of a sudden I learned about
the college Market wow they booked
comics for the colleges and so I became
an agent in my company Dave schwenson
entertainment DSE uh I was a agent in
the college market for about seven or
eight years NACA
and uh you know got a lot of comics gigs
through that and then um
the corporate Market I started getting
calls
just I mean again doing my workshops I
started those at the Cleveland improv I
do them now in Chicago and Tampa
um
but yeah they would hear about me and
they need a comedian for a holiday party
or a banquet
and that kind of stuff and I started you
know getting also like humor speakers
through the college market and I worked
with variety groups things like that so
that's really where that took off so
when I started learning more about the
corporate Market how that works and um I
do some myself I do I don't schedule
shows anymore but I do about 40 myself a
year gigs uh just for different things
you know colleges uh senior citizens
businesses whatever it might be
um but here's I mean the story this
isn't one of my you know I've written
three books guys
um I should hold them up I got them
somewhere around here
I feel like I'm so I feel like I'm
bragging I don't want to do that you ask
for my back telling you yeah what it is
so yeah you're giving us it's relevant
yeah okay you're just not I want people
to say oh God he's so cool he's doing
that no I'm a jerk just like everyone
else I just happen to know how to do
this stuff
[Laughter]
I've written three books on the comedy
industry the first one probably the best
known one is called how to be a working
comic
and um it's I consider it a business
book there are other books out there
that say how to write a joke how to blah
blah blah there's plenty of those out
there mine is a business book you know
how to get on stage how to do this
um
and after that came out
I started getting questions really
literally from around the world I mean
the New York City publisher with that
one Watson guptail was the publisher of
BCI Communications they do uh backstage
magazine billboard oh they're pretty big
and so I know it was translated
different languages I was getting emails
from around the world with questions
like how do you do this or how do you do
that so I started and I would always
answer the questions I'm really good at
that by email
and then uh I had a lot of comedian you
know my friends or comedians so I had
the opportunity to ask them questions
I'll never forget this one of the guys I
talked to was the late and the Great
Richard Jenny okay this guy was a comedy
writing machine you could not talk to
him without him coming up with a new bit
it was just he was to me I thought he
was just amazing and um I I talked to
him and I said I had a question that was
sending this is from my book comedy FAQs
and answers and something about the
corporate market and I'm saying you know
we really didn't know anything about
that he told me how he discovered the
corporate Market he was living in New
York City doing gigs you know clubs and
everything he said his agent called him
up and said you know Richard I've got a
uh I got a corporate gig for you
he goes what do you mean corporate gig
what the heck is that he says you put on
a suit you do your act and they pay you
ten thousand dollars he said [__] it
book more of those he says all of a
sudden I'm a corporate [__]
mm-hmm
so
yeah and then I started you know I I
found a lot of that going on more so you
know like I said in the midwest kind of
stuff I mean of course it's big industry
in New York now in Hollywood
but um yeah
so that's my story and I'm still kind of
mainly right now I just do workshops I
just finished the comedy workshop at the
Tampa Improv last month I start one at
the Cleveland improv uh April 22nd sold
out with a waiting list nice hoping to
get back hoping to get back to the
Chicago improv sometime this summer
and um I do a lot of private coaching
Zoom
and I do online uh comedy writers groups
on Mondays and Wednesdays at seven
o'clock Eastern time on Zoom just six
people at a time it's limited and uh the
goal is to come up with a good
new five minutes of material
which is you know that's that's not easy
to write good five minutes of material
that then it's a writer's group so we
critique each other and talk and things
like you know and I talk a lot about the
business getting work and things and
um yeah it's a four week session two
hours
a session for four four weeks and I've
been doing that since the pandemic
because I had a sold out Workshop right
as the pandemic hit and then in fact the
wind we're supposed to start on a
Saturday and I remember the Wednesday I
called up the club this was the
Cleveland improv I called up and says
are we still doing this what the heck's
going on with this pandemic and it was
told you know no we're doing it we never
cancel any shows it's an improv we
canceled it was the next day Thursday I
get a call from my other friend with
Craig over there was the manager he goes
it's Armageddon we're closing we never
cancel shows here The Improv and this is
a great night of Workshop starting
Saturday morning but we would have taken
it online and it worked out really well
and um so one thing I point out too in
the comics you know they say oh it's not
the same doing online stuff and
everything but guess what people are
still making money from it they're still
getting paid doing these shows I do I do
you know uh webinar kind of things and I
get people watching and
Asia and South America and Europe
you know it would I would never be able
to talk to them in person
so whatever
yeah and you you working with so many
comedians and we will we will uh
definitely want to get into like the
corporate transition all that but this
was just top of mind is there's I know
we have some newer Comics watching live
and like Jerry said he's been following
you on LinkedIn for a while and has your
first book and Mary found you from Jerry
on LinkedIn so that's very cool but
thank you you working with so many
comedians what are some of the most like
common mistakes you're seeing like young
Comics make
they still think we're living back in
the 70s they still think it's shock
value it's not
um now there is an audience for
everything don't get me wrong and I
always say this with the comics I coach
I am not out to turn anyone into Barney
the dinosaur G-rated Comics I'm not my
favorite Comics I could mention Dave
Attell I could mention Dom Herrera I
could mention Bobby Slade I mean I just
you know uh I I don't want to mention
everybody's name there's too many of
them but I mean I just love it push the
envelope I mean it's stand-up comedy yes
you know you can say things that you
can't really say anywhere else now that
I've said that
it's also a business
it's a creative art
it's no different than writing a book
painting a picture writing a song
singing a song it's a creative art you
must be able to express yourself but if
you want to make a living at this
you've got especially starting out when
you're a headliner don't remember when
you're a headliner you can say or do
anything you want Dave Chappelle could
say or do anything he wants okay so can
Leno so can all those household names
they can do whatever they want I
specifically work with people wanting to
break in the business how can they make
a living do it how can they quit their
day job and be comedians okay there's no
shortcut
there's no formula to write a joke
that's when I laugh when people say they
got a book on how to write comedy
material how to write a joke what are
you just could be a clone of that person
it's self-expression you know what makes
you laugh what is your sense I can't
tell someone a pie in the face is funny
if they don't think so okay that's how I
look at it
um but when you're starting out the most
important thing and again I keep saying
these things like this first of all I
want to make it very very clear to
everyone I am not a comedy teacher
I get offended when people say oh he's a
teacher he's a comedy teacher you can't
teach anyone comedy
you can't you have your own sense of
humor I have my own sense of humor you
could tell right now my sense of humor
kind of sucks
so yeah I think I'm funny but I'm not
anyway so I can't I can't teach you
cannot teach somebody what's funny they
have their own sense of humor I'm a
coach
for sure I'm the guy that people want
they yeah they want to do this so many
people want to do this but they're
afraid or they don't know what to do
they don't know where to start they
don't know how to Market themselves they
don't know how to you know write the
material they need to get on stage my
job I look at this is I'm the one that
kicks him in the butt boom
to get them on stage how are you going
to do this I'm scared I have stage right
we'll be prepared be prepared know what
you're gonna say before you go up there
that's all and then know your audience
here's the other thing how are you going
to get on St how are you going to get
stage time
and this gets it to the corporate Market
because I do work with a lot of people
you know interested in the corporate
Market you're not going to develop a
corporate comedy set going to some late
night beer soaked open mic with a bunch
of 20-something Comics sitting there and
it's their social night out I'm sorry
nothing against 20 something Comics I
mean that's when I started that's what's
my favorite you know comics
but that's different if you want to be
in the corporate Market you got to go in
front of that audience where you can
practice the corporate material where is
that it's not in a bar at midnight on a
Monday night or Thursday night they're
not sitting there because they gotta get
them go to work the next day
so you got to take your comedy material
where they are going to be how are you
going to do that okay I talk in my books
I call it the corporate comedy open mic
scene
every town every village every city they
have these associations rotary clubs
Knights of Columbus women's college
groups kiwanas they have meetings like
every week
and they're always looking for speakers
or entertainment
that's and they're the people that hire
you for corporate gigs okay
and you can't go in there talking about
your intimate details of your sex life
or how you go to the bathroom every hour
and what's left in the toilet you know
any drunk I mean it's it's it's until
you get it that's how you get a net
reputation as a hack it's easy to write
bathroom humor and drunk humor hello
what can you do
um and and to get the stage time
and even not even if you want to go into
corporate Market okay if you wanna
you you can only get good by going on
stage there's no shortcut
you want to get on stage as often as you
can
so there are other venues like
fundraisers
benefit shows talent shows but you can't
go in there with an x-rated Act
again I'm not trying to change anyone
there are plenty of comics like I
remember one time I said the Lisa
Lampanelli I said uh uh with what she
was doing or something I said I said
you'll never get on The Tonight Show
doing that material and she said [__]
you Dave I don't want to be on The
Tonight Show
she goes I want to be on the Howard
Stern Show
and it's true okay and some of the other
names I mentioned I mean they work dirty
or adult blue humor and that's fine
there's places they can work but you
must make that decision what you want to
do and my advice to the newer comedians
is to work cleaner just to get the stage
time
just to get your timing down your
delivery down and the thing is if you
can write a joke with a punch line
doesn't depend on like a shock value or
a you know an x-rated word you can
always add that stuff in later when you
have that audience
the Smart Ones do that
you know the stuff I'm not making up
this stuff by the way this is all told
to me by Comedians and professionals or
my own personal experience
you know I know comedians I've I've
booked comedians at
um years ago at the Hollywood improv we
did a midnight blue show on Friday
nights just as filthy as they want to be
then Monday morning the same Comics
don't mention any names that they know
I'm thinking of them uh Monday morning
they can have a suit on at stand at
corporate boardroom talk about the same
topics but it's G-rated
mm-hmm
okay it's it's it's knowing about the
business it's it's the business
again it's a creative art I respect that
I I feel I'm creative myself with my
writing and everything but
you know it's it's a lot of sitting
around telling yourself how great you
are and how creative you are but if no
one's hiring you who knows
yeah yeah so as a for
you gave some common things that young
Comics do
uh anything for like established
comedians that have been doing comedy
for a while sort of how they transition
into the corporate world no they're all
smart enough to figure that out they
know that
gotcha I mean I what else can I tell you
know
you know if you've done a corporate gigs
you guys have both done some corporate
stuff right well you know you walk in
I mean it's Common Sense know your
audience know your audience I remember
one time and here's something
a lot of comics don't realize too and
you want to break into the college
Market
okay they always think oh yeah colleges
the college kids
the students will love me because I'm
going to talk about sleeping in and
missing classes and smoking pot and
getting high getting drunk I'm going to
get laid Yeah that college kids love
that yeah the college kids too but guess
what who hires you
Student Activities
and they have a Student Activities board
and they got a Student Activities
advisor and they're booking shows for
the newer comedians again Headliners can
do whatever they want
but you're breaking into college Market
guess what shows you're going to be
trying to get little sibs weekend family
weekend alumni weekend parents weekend
they don't want to sit there and listen
to what you
sleeping in getting high in and getting
laid
okay I mean just really so when I talk
about established comedians they know
this I'm not saying anything they don't
know
you know it's it's common sense and if
you can't figure that out you're not
going to work
you guys asked
to ask I just say what it is I don't
know of course yeah and I think yeah
Yoshi and I have both done I mean we've
done like stand up in like a corporate
setting and also like workshops and team
building and things like that and we'd
like to do more and actually find maybe
some stable work through that and right
now I know I know for mine personally
it's basically been Word of Mouth some
people have found the podcast and found
the educational value that could apply
to like their sales team and other
people have just like heard about me
through someone else and it's kind of
been like a smaller networking side but
to really want to start building
momentum in this world you know
yes
yeah uh it is all about networking
um
you you have to treat it like a business
you know against when I talk about my
book how to be a working comic it is a
business book
I consider myself to be a businessman
I'm not a comedian
okay I mean I I booked shows I was a
talent coordinator I was behind the
scenes guy
and so a lot of the stuff I learned the
first edition of the book now it's been
updated how to be a working comic uh
because when it first came out it was
like the hard copy
um
I don't have anything around like like a
folder you have your eight by ten in it
your resume your bio and all you know
those days are gone everything is online
now so we updated it so it involves like
online and emails and things like that
but you know you have to be
serious about doing this I mean you have
to it's a job it can't just be like okay
I'm not doing anything for a month I'll
sit down some morning and I'll send out
a bunch of emails doing hey I need my
comic hire me
you know they're these Talent Bookers
they get those emails every day
you know how you have to find a way to
stay in touch without being a pain in
the butt but also you can't let them
forget about you you got to be good I
mean Steve Martin said you gotta be so
good they can't ignore you
um
okay so I mean just a lot of the
mistakes I see from the newer comedians
they come in they they decide also
they're going to be a comedian and you
know listen I I appreciate I mean so
what a great career that would be to be
a comedian and people love comedy but
like I've said there's no such thing as
an overnight success so they'll come in
I've had people take my workshops I do
my workshops are three Saturdays that
have performance at the Improv in front
of a big crowd for many of them it's
their first time on stage it's what an
excitement what a rush that is and it
works for them because they're practiced
we've rehearsed it we talk about it we
rewrite it you know they get on stage
every session at The Improv and I I'm
Simon Cowell that's not funny you know
or how can we make that money so when
they go they do this but I've had a few
that say oh yeah Dave as soon as I
finish a workshop I'm moving to
Hollywood I'm gonna get a sitcom
and I'm like
it just knocks the breath I'm like
oh don't don't do that don't you'll
never get on stage you know I mean if
you live there and you're starting out
that's different if you live in New York
City you're starting out that's
different but get your experience under
the radar somewhere
you know and get on stage as much as you
can because it's all about trial and
error when I when I talk about this
writing and creating new comedy material
in my workshops we're making a we're
making our best guess
you don't know nobody knows
how it's going to work until you get on
stage in front of an audience
okay uh and and that's that's the only
way to do this I don't know how I got I
think I got off track of what you guys
asked me I don't know but yeah we're
we're asking you how we can work in the
corporate world more yeah basically yeah
okay working yeah okay thanks I'm
helping you guys out right
yes this is now a coaching session yes
all right do you guys have venmo what
are you guys doing here yeah
yeah
I think coming back to which I think is
super important is knowing your audience
and then finding a way to get on stage
in front of that audience you mentioned
rotary clubs you mentioned fundraisers
you mentioned
um talent shows but things that where
corporate people are going to be not
necessarily dive bars and uh breweries
because you may not find your corporate
audience there so I think right that
seems to be the theme that keeps coming
back as I'm taking notes Here is that
just knowing your audience and knowing
that if we're trying to go more
corporate is to find ways in front of
corporate audiences and get on corporate
stages as much as possible yeah that is
what I call and you know you guys you
guys have I mean I have my copy of it I
mean you know my book right you've seen
this how to be a working corporate
comedian because I used to teach an
online course and this kind of stuff and
I was like what the heck it's like it's
all it's written a book but it's a
chapter it's called the corporate comedy
open mic scene
and basically I mean again you have to
get on stage so I would say open mics
like a a necessary evil I can't tell you
how much I hear from Comics how much
they hate open mics
all right it's a bunch of other Comics
sitting there all they're always paying
attention to because they're all working
on their act you know and if you get a
real audience that's that's great if you
can do that then you get bringer shows I
don't know when that started uh we
didn't have bringer shows and I was
doing this in New York
um but yeah the corporate comedy open
mic scene is if you want to get into the
corporate Market you got to find your
audience you have to write for that
audience
okay so again I mean like
you know an example of this stuff and
again I don't make this up I learned
this working with NSA NASA yeah the
National Speakers Association
um
when I decided to get I do corporate
training programs I use like humor
communication skills teamwork networking
you know team building that kind of
stuff and um
to put this together I did what I called
the corporate comedy open mic scene
rotary clubs
okay Knights of Columbus women's college
groups everything within a driving
distance of where I was at that time I
called them up and um asked if I can
come in and you know they need a speaker
at every meeting
and uh they don't pay
but it's an open mic they feed you it's
better than any open mic I did in New
York so you know they could be a big
meal and everything you go in and and I
got to to work this out in front of them
I'd have my notes they'd give you a
lectern and I have my notes on there
because I wasn't a big professional
getting paid for this
and and trying things out and audience
participation I was doing and I can't
tell you how many I did I mean just
tons and uh everywhere I could drive
breakfast lunch dinner Banquets
different all different I mean six
o'clock in the morning I'm a night
person I'm in the comedy world six
o'clock in the morning I'm standing
there trying to do a corporate thing
that's an hour drive already in the snow
um
but it came together that way that's how
I put it together and my first paying
gig doing that it was for a rotary club
somewhere
and when I finished and I oh and I
always you got to handle like a business
so you always have business cards I'm
just surprised that people are like oh
that's old-fashioned business cards but
that's why you're not getting work hello
instead of write your name down on a
napkin piece of paper or say hey here's
my email address email me block you got
a card boom it's right on there here
take this I handed out cards I had a gig
this afternoon I'm handing out cards
um
I did this for a rotary club and at the
end I'm standing by the doors people are
leaving I'm thanking them for allowing
me to come in thank you I hope you
enjoyed it you know everything like that
and you know handing out a business card
if they'd like one to get in touch with
me and one guy came up and he was a
dentist and they were having an American
Dental Association some kind of meeting
there and he asked if I would like to
come speak for 500 bucks
and it was just what I just did in the
rotary for free so I'm like you want to
pay me for what I just did for free yes
you got a deal
and and you know and then it networks
from there because you got a credit then
you got your resume going and and you
have to Market it you have to Market
um
you know and you know that's why I
talked about the open mic scene like
that you put together a clean that you
you network you get to know people you
find ways to get their business cards
start mailing lists I mean I've done
this okay I've got I've written a couple
books besides the comedy industry where
I have like a contest or something drop
your business card in the champagne
bucket I'm spinning around we'll draw
one out you'll win a copy of my book all
the rest of you will go on my email list
and I will send you a monthly newsletter
there's always an unsubscribe button so
you don't need to and if you don't like
me I can disappear into cyberspace you
won't hurt my feelings but you could put
your business card in you got a chance
to win a book I used to have like passes
from The Improv you know things like
that I get whatever
and people would put their
business cards in and I developed a
mailing list an email list
I have a couple email lists now I'm
assuming both you guys are on my how to
be a working comic humorous speaker
email list I send out a newsletter every
two weeks
and it has you know like but we're
talking about business stuff this week I
think the one is about bombing bombing
on stage
and uh I sent out every two weeks so I
have my email list
but you do that you stay in touch with
people and um
you know the other thing too uh I cold
call
it's it's a miserable thing to do
but
I don't know I I call I cold call who I
want to talk to what am I going to talk
to where are these groups
and you've got a phone it's miserable
it's miserable
you get somebody who doesn't know what
they're talking about you get the you
know the gatekeeper and you leave a
message then you got to call back I keep
Excel programs so I know when I called
who I talked to what I talked about
again it's a business you can't just do
this it's spur of the moment say oh yeah
it's a hobby I'm going to do comedy as a
hobby
well then be happy performing in a
holiday and on a Friday night you know
that's that's it you want to make you
want to make it in the business you
treat it like a business
[Laughter]
that was a nice holiday end but I
appreciate it there's a Holiday Inn
Express so it's got free breakfast
you know
free breakfast I'm such a jerk and I
know that
he's like you want to get in the
corporate world where you're staying in
Hilton's that's when you know you've
made it
when there isn't free breakfast because
oh yeah yes
so Dave like when when you think about
sort of where you've been with your
comedy journey and sort of uh how
comedy has changed now what would you
give sort of as advice of how Comics can
sort of what do they need to leverage
Now versus the way that they used to
think because I think there's still a
lot of comedians that sort of are
beholden to Gatekeepers and like are
just waiting for somebody else to tell
them oh you're the star now now how do
you how would you sort of advise Comics
how do they make it on their own sort of
to write their own story
it's a very interesting question
uh you have to take charge
of what you're doing
um I'm trying to think like when I when
I talk because again my my affiliation
has been with the Improv
since the 1980s and I stand on the stage
and I tell the audience of the number
one comedy club in the world I don't
care who there's nobody can disagree
with me that's that's what it is
um but I also know it's hard to get into
the club it's hard to get bookings there
and you know I tell everyone don't put
all your eggs in one basket
it's not the only Club out there I mean
there's there's Zanies you know there's
the funny bone there's Levity Live
there's no helium there's there's all
these different clubs coconuts I guess
that you know whatever you know
get your stuff out there if the Improv
doesn't book you it's not the end of the
world
there's there are plenty other clubs but
again you've got to
you know you've got to treat it like a
business
um it's it's networking it's getting
it's getting on stage it's it's meeting
other comedians without being a pain in
the butt
but you know sometimes you work with
that's important that's important I
can't tell you how many times I've heard
from comedians like oh God this person's
coming they won't leave me alone I've
had that happen to me
you know like just okay they're not my
style I just can't work with that person
kind of stuff because they're a pain in
the butt but you know if you're working
with someone who is getting bookings
their National act or something and they
say they like your set they think you're
funny you know ask them for advice
you know what do you think I should do
next you know is there a talent Booker I
can you know look you've got to network
you know if they don't like you they
don't think you're funny they're not
going to do it they're not going to ruin
their career to help out someone they
don't believe in but if they really do
believe in you
see a lot of comics don't understand
this there are age they always say I
need an agent I need a manager well you
know they're looking for new faces
there they they look I mean how do you
think they make money
they gotta find you know all the big
major stars are already represented you
know so there's there's plenty of Agents
out there managers looking
for talent that they could nurture
so they can both make money that's what
it's about it's a business I'm sorry I'm
sorry that's what it is it's a business
and
you know you just have to be like Steve
Martin said you have to be so funny they
can't ignore you but you have to let you
let them know you're out there
um
getting on stage you know networking of
I I don't know what to say that they
will find you but you know if you're not
ready don't try to push yourself on
someone if you're not ready you've got
to be honest
I mean I've I've known comedians
personally uh I've heard stories and
stuff where they just weren't ready they
thought they were they did like a you
know two weeks worth of open mics and
they think okay they're ready for The
Tonight Show
and then they they actually you know and
the horrible thing is they'll pull like
one of those lottery numbers like you
have for your auditions you always have
one of those they know the Improv we had
a lottery
and they'll pull the number they'll get
on stage and they don't have any
experience they've only been doing it
for a year and they think they're
Headliners and they bomb horribly and
the bottom line is and it's awful to say
this a lot of these casting people
Talent boogers they remember first
impressions
um it's tough you make a lousy first
impression it's tough to get over that
um
so you've got to be honest with yourself
how do you how do you stand up you know
against the other comedians are you
getting as many laughs are you getting
you know and plus you can do this on
your own too and I'll tell you that's
why I wrote the book how to be a working
comic you don't need an agent when
you're starting out you don't need a
manager you don't need a publicist why
would you want to pay these people all
this extra money when you can do this
yourself right now
all right you don't need those people
until you get so busy you can't handle
it yourself but right now what are you
doing
we're sitting here talking on a podcast
right we can stay instead of doing that
we could be writing material hey you
know we're doing whatever okay
so you know I tell them that you know
you can you do this you be your own
manager you be your own agent
you know be your own publicist get your
headshots together get your video
together you know get your resume
together you know you can do that it's
easy stuff that's all the agents and
managers do and when they started out in
their business their careers and I've
known some big time agents and managers
very very successful but I know they
started out also having to pick up the
phone and make calls
I'm an angel I'm representing so yeah
you're an agent right
no really I'm an agent I got this hire
my people you know and
it takes time
and the dedication a lot of people fall
off to the Wayside because it's too much
work they find it's too hard
but uh you know
it's a job you know it's not a job that
has to be 24 7 either I mean set away
some time do it I mean I set away time
every week to do you find me on LinkedIn
you find me on these things and it's not
like a Spur the moment like oh I got
nothing to do I'm gonna sit down and do
this no man I got my got my bottle of
water I got the next hour let's let's
spam
do you get a lot of because I know
you're consistent on LinkedIn and I feel
I mean even if it's something as like
just posting an interesting article that
relates to humor and things like that do
you get a lot of leads on LinkedIn or
what kind of value you're getting
posting so much on LinkedIn
I get a lot of people contacting me like
you guys just did because again my main
focus really when it comes to Comedy is
I'm a coach so I do private coaching I
do the my online coaching a Monday
Wednesday evenings and I do my workshops
and so I get a lot of leads that way
uh when I do my
um and and really so much I'm not really
doing that much corporate training stuff
anymore like I was because I didn't have
as much fun as I am now I I do a um
well like again when I go out instead of
like a big long like a training seminar
thing I do like a one-hour comedy
Workshop
for corporate or 55 and older
communities I do it for high schools I
do it I do video conferences I just did
one for two of them for Niagara Falls
couple weeks ago and I was down in
Florida doing it okay
um
it's yeah I mean I you know it's it's
really networking it's getting the word
out it's getting the word I guess on
LinkedIn it may be how they find because
they contact me but I do a lot of again
cold calling I do a lot of emailing I
have my email lists
um and again I'm interested in comedy I
love it so if I see an article that I
think makes sense
you know I mean I've got
you know LinkedIn and and uh what else
do I do now Instagram I do Tick Tock and
I've got like three different Facebook
pages how to be a working comic how to
be comedy workshops online comedy
workshops so if I find articles that are
interesting
about the business or something you know
I
I post it and usually I can find
something every day because I'm looking
for that that's what I look for it so
I'm interested in
and especially by someone I'd worked
with in the past
I'm like oh you know I'm really happy
for their success
you're like oh they're actually doing
something now this is great I can put it
out and I can say hey I remember when I
worked with so and so and it's you know
look how far they've taken this because
they haven't given up
yeah nice
it's a Kuma set I'm outside smoking weed
like you're talking about treating it
like a job and he's like yeah I'm
outside smoking weed
because that side of comedy as well but
it is like you said treating it like a
job I mean so comedy is something that's
a get out what you put in a lot of the
time as well yeah but you know a lot of
it is a lot of it is living
and
I didn't take my workshop and stuff I
have the George Carlin writing technique
I have stuff that these communities told
me how they write material how they put
together the bottom line is
you live your life you live and you talk
about it
comedians are observers of life you know
they're they're journalists they're how
they feel about things what they observe
what they see and everything and you
can't do that if you're sitting around
in front of a computer screen trying to
write oh the big thing the big thing the
big mistakes the biggest mistake too
when I start working with someone
they think they're going to sit down in
front of their laptop or their computer
every night and write for an hour I'm
gonna sit down every night at 10 o'clock
I'm gonna write till 11 o'clock every
night and usually nine times out of ten
even more than that an hour later
they're still staring at a blank screen
you know and the comics I talked to
they go out and do stuff I mean they go
out and do stuff and things happen and
they write about it
I remember I remember here's a story
from years ago I was at the when I was
running the Cleveland improv my good
friend Bobby Collins who I just love
uh he was our headliner and he was
coming in from California it was a major
snowstorm airports were all closed and
just storm you know snowing like crazy
and uh we're keeping track of his flight
we had a full audience the place was
sold out like oh man so I'm looking
around and there were Comics that had
taken my workshop in the audience to
watch this and I'm putting them on stage
to do five minutes you did five minutes
the workshop can you do it now can you
do it re-extending the show we found
when the plane landed we had a car
waiting for him he the car hauled him
through the snowstorm I think he ran I
remember him running in the door just
throwing off his coat and everything we
announced him he goes up on stage and uh
he gets up there talks about the
snowstorm he says oh my God you know we
landed we're skinning on the runway and
blah blah blah this and that this and
that anyway to finish this set I went
over and said Bobby I said ah man it was
awful about that snowstorm he goes what
do you mean he said I just got a new
three minutes yeah
really yeah that's how it works I mean
Christopher Titus told me the story one
time he's getting arrested they're
putting his head in the black at a
police car and it's got the handcuffs
he's thinking oh man I got a good I got
a new five minutes
yeah so you know it's it's so when I
talk about being a business I mean you
are a creative artist I don't want to
underestimate that part of it you you
have to it is like being a painter
you're an artist
and so you live your life You observe it
and um you know where's the humor
where's your humor fit in something you
know someone else's thinking something
is funny you don't find it funny at all
but you'll find something that you think
is just hysterical and you have to share
it
but you know it's through an experience
nice
uh yeah so as we land This Plane is
there any closing are you kidding I'm
all talked out I can't believe you guys
let me go on like this no I just want if
you had any closing your favorite comedy
advice or anything else you
I want to say before we land the plane
here Dave or or at everything or or what
your favorite comedy story that nobody
knows about that is a hot breath
exclusive from all the names that you
dropped today that no one's ever heard
before but only you can share okay well
there was the time I almost killed Dave
Chappelle
[Laughter]
please expand
well I've been in this business a long
time right so his Heat
yeah and uh met Dave Chappelle uh in in
Hollywood at the Hollywood improv the
idea auditioned that's another long
story
but um he came out through a friend of
mine in New York who's his agent and I
at least one of the only people I ever
put on stage without watching him first
he was a New York Comic I was in
Hollywood anyway he would not be killed
he was just great so funny and so uh
when he's coming off the stage you know
I ran up to him and
said you're going to do the TV show
evening at The Improv and he was a
regular now on the roster at the
Hollywood Improv so I was booking the
shows then and I was sitting in the back
of the Hollywood improv uh one night and
this
had that corner of my eye I saw somebody
walk up to me it was Dave Chappelle and
I look up and I said you know hey man
what are you doing here he says you gave
me a spot like at 8 30. he gave me a
nine o'clock spot I'm like yeah but not
here that was in Santa Monica we had a
Santa Monica improv at that time I'm in
the Hollywood Improvement yeah not here
it's in Santa Monica he goes oh man he
says I'm from New York I don't have a
car
so my whole thing was
it would look really bad for him to miss
a spot okay it would look extra bad for
him to be hanging out with me the talent
coordinator while he's missing the spot
so I said I said all right I said go
let's get my car so he had another
friend with him a guy by the name of
Dave
um
Dave Edwards did a lot of college work
at the time so three day Dave schwenson
Dave Chappelle Dave Edwards we run out
of the Hollywood improv I got this
feeder of a a lemon of a car I had a
Mustang convertible it sucked I only got
it because it was a convertible and I
thought it would look cool I didn't know
it would break down every month whatever
kind of stuff anyway so these guys jump
in Dave Edwards is in the back seat Dave
Chappelle's sitting next to me and I'm
driving and we're heading out to Santa
Monica we have like 15 minutes or 10
whatever to get there and so I don't
know what high I can't remember the
highway anymore 405 I don't know why
we're on I'm doing like 90.
and uh I'm passing cars and Dave
Chappelle's sitting next to me and he
put his feet up but he put his hands on
the dashboard like this and he's
screaming he's going he's going oh my
God I could see it now with the
headlines three Daves died in fiery car
accident and I'm getting them I'm going
shut up shut up like this and I'm
driving in the Dave Edwards in the
backseat three days we get down to the
Santa Monica improv I pull up right in
front of the club right I slam on the
brakes boom and I said get out
and the two of them jumped out of the
car and Chappelle went in he was just
like one minute before his set was right
but he got there he made it okay so
that's that part of the story now a few
years later
okay he's a big star he's got the
Chappelle show he's got a tour bus he's
not his big head shot if you ever saw a
tour bus it's a big picture Dave
Chappelle on the side big I was hand I
was managing the Cleveland improv and he
was doing the show so I was there and I
pulled up and everything I look out in
the parking lot and there's this bus
this Dave Chappelle bus so I thought
well I'll go over I don't know if he
remembers me or not or anything like
this so I went over to the bus and had
the curtains were all closed and
everything so I went over and I knocked
on the door like this and I expected one
of his guys or something to look out and
say who are you
and knocked on the door at a bus next I
know the curtain opens up the window and
Dave Chappelle looks out at me and he
goes hey three Daves die in fiery car
accidents
that's incredible
I hung out the bus got a contact high
and went to work
[Laughter]
that's glorious well Dave thank you so
much for sharing that story and sharing
your time for people listening to this
where would you what would you like them
to check out on your end how can they
check out your books and anything you
want
uh just go to my website which is the
t-h-e comedy book The comedybook.com and
I have links on there to take you to all
the other stuff I do again I we're
starting online comedy workshops again
and in two weeks private coaching and
zoom and also my comedy workshops mainly
Cleveland Chicago Tampa
but uh sign up for my newsletter it's
free every other week I send out a
newsletter and um yeah my books are all
on Amazon how to be a working comic
comedy FAQs and answers and the one
we're supposed to be talking about today
which is how to be a working corporate
comedian Kaboom I got 40 40 some Comics
I work with give their advice again it's
not me making up stuff it's all working
Comics sharing what they do how to help
you in the business yeah by the way I've
got it I've been reading it uh for like
the past year I got it about a year ago
great book it didn't take a year to
write it it took a year to read it
but you've got exercises you've got
literal exercises in there
it's a great book because when I started
it so here's a funny thing when I
started it I started I was like oh this
is like a workbook like I didn't realize
it was a workbook I thought I would just
like read it and then but you've got
work exercises which was amazing so I'm
like literally going through each of the
work exercises making sure I have it so
but yeah it's awesome that's what I like
about it I'm glad you brought that up
because there is another thing I want to
promote here which um I haven't been
promoting it as much because it's kind
of new from me but you know those
courses they have on udemy
yeah you're familiar with you to me
right so we put together a course how to
be a working comic and it's on you to me
and there are gosh I know it's all the
videos I mean it's me and it's like step
by step how to become a working comic
again it's about how to write comedy
material how to get on stage business
stuff uh marketing promotions all that
stuff it's on you to me I think it's
like a
it might be like a 32 course but they're
always having those things on sale for
like 16 bucks or whatever but yeah
there's um
I mean there's like 50 some downloadable
things articles to read and homework you
know I want you there's like five
sections so you have to you know you got
to finish section one then go to section
two and yeah you know and again it's not
an overnight thing it's just to give me
an idea and oh and every every video
there's like at least 26 videos I did
for this everyone I drop a comedian's
name
so someone you might have heard of I'm
telling you what they told me their
advice a lot of famous people and some
that aren't so famous but you know some
good advice so it's on you to me uh
udemy udem well I don't know how you
spell that who cares uh how to be a
working comic an Insider's Guide an
Insider's Guide to a career and stand-up
comedy and you can watch and you can
watch Davis I haven't Dave TV you can
watch me for hours
anytime you don't like what I say you
just hit the button it's like you know
like censorship boom
we'll definitely put uh links to all
your stuff yeah in the the show notes of
this episode and
um yeah thank you so much Dave for your
time
I had a blast talking with you guys by
the way I know sometimes I'm whatever
but I was having fun
amazing yeah yeah you killed it Dave my
favorite moment was you roasting Yoshi
for how long he's taken with your book
that was but it it sounds like writing a
book is a good like a good Resume
Builder for like corporate stuff seems
like that adds a bit of credibility to
the brand
a lot of what I'm doing now matter of
fact when I said I had a gig today again
not to keep you guys on for a lot of
people don't know this about me I've
written two books on the Beatles okay uh
completely different
person I mean I have different Facebook
groups LinkedIn groups but the comics
find out I wrote two books in The
Beatles they're like what the hell are
you doing Dave I'm like well I just you
know anyway
um that's my gig I had this afternoon I
go out and talk to groups about the
1960s and the Beatles concerts at the
beginning of Stadium Rock and I showed
some rare videos and uh I do as I do as
many of those as I do with my comedy
stuff and it's completely different I
love that completely different so if
anyone's interested that's the same
right like you're still a speaker you're
still being funny you're still
presenting yeah I work on I work off the
audience I have a lot of fun I asked
them for their memories that kind of
stuff and uh oh yeah I had a lot of fun
with the group today I just I I
yeah if anyone's interested in something
like that it's Beatles
b-e-a-t-l-e-sprogram.com
beetlesprogram.com and it has my books
and
stuff on there my calendar
man I'm all talked out you guys you're a
great day
we appreciate you Dave anyone listening
reach out to Dave if you enjoyed this
let them know that his time and
information is very well spent here in
the hot breadth of verse and uh we will
be back next Tuesday so thank you
everyone for hanging out thank you Dave
all right thank you guys it was great a
lot of fun thank you good luck he might
roast your dreams but he's a good guy
and he loves you regardless
wow
have a good day everyone we love you all
appreciate it Dave thank you